we'll figure it out okay I promise no we
have to get to Mississippi before
Trinity we have to find the silver bomb
okay but first we're gonna help these
people get to safety and then we'll go
after the box I have to go you don't
know that cause of this Laura not
everything is about you the Lara Croft
who appears in shadow of the Tomb Raider
has made a ton of discoveries lost a lot
of friends and killed countless living
beings she has incredible Drive and
self-confidence and her enemies fear her
it's taken a lot for the character to
get to this point and if you've been
along for the ride since her excellent
revival in 2013's Tomb Raider you may be
pleased to hear that shadow of the Tomb
Raider is the same style of experience
we first saw in 2013 only bigger and
with more added to it in fact there's
seemingly very little if anything that's
changed dramatically or being discarded
from the formula but while that means
shadow retains a lot of the components
that give Tomb Raider that fantastic
timeless sense of wonder and discovery
it also means that two made his
interpretation of blockbuster
action-adventure mechanics is starting
to feel half a decade old and this is
the first of many catastrophes you're
doing you would have done the same it's
a little unnerving to spend time with
the seasoned Dallara in shadow of the
Tomb Raider because her experience has
changed her into a hardened obsessive
and selfish individual she's reached
true colonizer form determined to get
the game's MacGuffin blind to collateral
damage much to their concern of her
lovable partner Jonah
her demeanor is reflected in a renewed
focus on stealth where the new mechanics
and the jungle setting give Lara the
opportunity for predator style ambushes
she can cover herself in mud for
additional camouflage string enemies up
from a tree and craft fear errors which
cause humans to freak out and attack
each other
[Applause]
you're also now able to transition back
into stealth after being discovered
provided you can get away and break a
line of sight there's a big emphasis on
these new abilities as tooltips
throughout the entire game will
continually remind you that they exist
but while her expanded skillset gives
you more options to confidently and
quietly hunt everyone on the map it also
highlights the cracks and
inconsistencies in tomatos enemy logic
and the limitations of the game's
relatively unsophisticated call stealth
mechanics sound still doesn't seem to
play a significant factor in to manage
stealth while firing at someone and
throwing objects will draw attention
moving through rustling vegetation and
making loud footsteps doesn't seem to
faze anyone even though the game
suggests that it will normal taking out
a soldier behind another with his back
turned but those rules also see
malleable there were sections in the
game where my attempted stealth approach
went wrong
a gunfight broke out and after the dust
settled I was shocked to discover an
additional patrol of guards in the same
area only a few seconds away from the
action carrying on with a conversation
as if nothing had happened
Lara's survival instincts ability will
once again give you information on which
enemies are safe to quietly take down
without alerting others but it can also
reveal some puzzling inconsistencies in
enemy awareness logic there were too
many times where I was able to get away
with taking out a guard with one of his
co-workers staring right at us only
meters away other times the game will
tell you it's unsafe to take on an enemy
because of someone with line-of-sight
halfway across the arena you can't
always trust your own perception of the
map even if it seems obvious and using
survival instincts feels necessary to
constantly verify that the game agrees
with your idea of what is safe or unsafe
so expect to be taking out a lot of
bright yellow men in monochromatic
environments when playing on to mate is
hard combat difficulty which removes
enemy highlights this uncertain behavior
makes stealth even tougher than you
might think the new stealth abilities
also have their quirks though
camouflaging yourself with mud rightly
makes you harder to notice you can abuse
it to the extent where you can roll
right under the nose of a guard it's
thrilling for you but it makes you pity
the enemy mud is also typically
available at the on
set of major stealth sections or at
least very close to the hiding spots
that require it making the mechanic feel
more like an innate ability rather than
a tactical option you need to actually
seek out fear errors have
disappointingly varied results - more
than a few times I would find myself
stalking a patrol of men from a tree hit
the shotgun soldier with a fear arrow
with the goal of having him flaw his
friends and watch as he proceeded to
miss every point-blank shot there's
still some satisfaction to be gained in
shadows stealth so waiting with bated
breath for patrols to move on and
figuring out which order to eliminate
the guards like some kind of violent
logic puzzle is still enjoyable but the
new mechanics don't really add anything
significantly interesting to that
baseline experience the big spotlight on
them suggests a more sophisticated
stealth system that just isn't there you
get the feeling that Lara is the
cold-blooded predator that much is true
but it's not satisfying when the prey is
so dumb and easy now the game wants you
to know that this Lara is fearsome
she'll easily kill people in cutscenes
without even blinking an eye however
this depiction is betrayed by her actual
abilities in the game's toe-to-toe
combat where it's often tough to get
liar to act like that efficient killing
machine the game's guerrilla angle calls
for more close and personal encounters
and the greater number of small combat
arenas means that when things get
hostile soldier's closed the distance
quickly
additionally there are new melee enemies
who focus on rushing you down with
overwhelming numbers now we can't show
them to you here because it's a spoiler
but two metres existing combat mechanics
do not service this particular style of
hostilities well Lara's dodges are still
the hurried scuttle and roll from her
early days as an amateur survivor and
her climbing ax is still largely
ineffective as a melee option most
enemies will simply dodge her knockdown
attempts especially on the hard combat
difficulty melee doesn't become a viable
close-quarters tactic until you unlock a
dodge encounter skill later in the game
and most of the weapons in Lara's
arsenal are inefficient as close-range
keepo eight holes until the events of
the story give you a shotgun
additionally shadow of the Tomb Raider
still doesn't communicate damage
direction if you're getting overwhelmed
being attacked from the sides or behind
you won't know exactly where from
meaning it's more difficult to start
making smart evasive maneuvers on the
fly with so few certainties and reliable
tools to assist you in close quarters
combat these encounters typically result
in making Lara scurry clumsily in
whichever direction doesn't have enemies
coming from it and frantically trying to
create enough space to effectively use
your weapons
when shadow does throw you into a few
mid-range combat encounters though the
difference becomes really clear fighting
suppressing fire scampering from cover
to cover
throwing improvised Molotov and pinging
out head shot after head shot after head
shot feels empowering the combat
mechanics feel much more suited to these
scenarios as was the case in previous
games and it's only here where Lara can
feel like the ice-cold killer queen
she's become
shadow of the Tomb Raider is nothing if
not a gorgeous game and it features some
stellar level design both aesthetically
and mechanically the environments are
beautiful and exploring the impressively
dense locations in Mexico and Peru is a
joy jungles feel imposing an endless
Brewin tombs are intricately detailed
hub cities are enormous and lively and
it's easy to be completely distracted by
discovering new paths and areas hunting
down the games artifacts treasure chests
and numerous other collectables
however meaningless you think they are
is also still enjoyable as they give you
a reason to go sightseeing there's a lot
of emphasis on underwater exploration in
shadow - and while underwater sections
can be frustrating as part of story
missions because instant kill piranhas
that require you to hide in seaweed gets
pretty old pretty fast it's hard to
resist Swan diving into a huge body of
water when you get a chance to explore
on your own but its shadow of the tomb
Raider's numerous challenged tombs and
crypts that are the undisputed stars of
the show the impressive design of
ancient mechanisms and the obscure
solutions to using them and unlocking
the path forward feel amazing to
decipher after minutes of
head-scratching
the shadow of the Tomb Raider also
rewards you for completing these
activities with exclusive skills and
gear making them more than worth your
time traversing the treacherous
environments in these tombs as well as
during the game story missions is
thrilling in its own right - despite
their always being an expected sense of
peril the designs of Lara's foolhardy
paths between locations never get old
there's always some kind of dicey
maneuver at a terrifying height that
makes you hold your breath
but these exciting traversal puzzles
also feature their own unique moments of
frustration because though the locations
have changed since 2013
Lara's platforming skill set has
seemingly not her jumps across gaps
still feel floaty and inconsistent
meaning she'll sometimes get a
mysteriously divine boost in the air to
make sure she latches on to a faraway
edge but sometimes she might not grab on
to a Ledge at all even if she's easily
cleared the gap the same goes for Lara's
tool related maneuvers there are more
than enough instances where Lara
completely and amusingly whiffed grapple
axe or a zipline that calls her to
plummet to a death prompting me to check
that my controller was still connected
and that I still had my primary mode of
functions though jumps and traversal
maneuvers still feel loose in general
which makes them feel imprecise the way
she unconvincingly just flops her
climbing axes directly into solid rock
faces after jumping one to them always
raises an eyebrow altogether these
elements bring a dire uncertainty to
shadows more demanding traversal
sections every time you try and make a
jump it's a gamble the result you get
after jumping the first time might not
be the one you're supposed to get but
while that adds to the perilous nature
of the task and everything works out
fine most of the time it's annoying when
it doesn't when you can't completely
trust Lara's abilities to jump and grab
a Ledge that she's supposed to be able
to jump and grab that's a problem it's
these kinds of moments that make you
feel incredibly frustrated that 2-meters
core platforming mechanics don't seem to
have been refined in the past five years
a shadow of the tomato adds so many more
pieces to the formula of previous games
but there are also so many little things
that it just doesn't quite land the
game's obsession with collecting
crafting materials has only become more
profuse there are now 21 the different
items together causing everything to
seem less valuable and the act of
gathering them to be more of a chore the
side quests are poorly paced as each
will lead off with roughly 10 minutes of
fetch quests across the game's huge hubs
and watching Talking Heads before
getting to the meat of things may
it easy to lose motivation the game is a
really cool option for immersive
voiceovers which causes NPCs to speak in
their native languages that Lara
continues to speak to everyone in
English which feels like a missed
opportunity
esos animales lastime imijo Joe Marko
I'm not with ARMA believe me what's this
about your son and perhaps the most sad
of all is the fact that Lara herself
with her single-minded selfishness is a
harder character to empathize with in
shadow her attitudes and obsessions are
intertwined with the game's plot events
and you might find yourself in
disagreement with her a lot which is a
big deal when you're trying to overlook
the flaws in her abilities Jonah is the
one you'll be rooting for in this game
because he acts as Lara's center he'll
likely echo a lot of your own sentiments
and he has a more sympathetic arc it's a
shame that the liar you grew so
incredibly fond Oh in the tomato reboot
and the scrappy skills you use to help
her survive Yamatai have both grown to
be some of the most frustrating parts of
her latest adventure shadow of the Tomb
Raider makes you long for the days of a
Lara that was easier to empathize with
where being inexperienced and imprecise
made sense and there was only one
crafting resource together thankfully
the part of the two-minute series that
make it really fantastic when covering
the mystery of ancient ruins solving
impressive challenge terms and exploring
exotic environments are still here in
shadow and they are just as outstanding
as they have always been but the core
mechanics that have been with this
series for half a decade are starting to
show their limitations making the
journey to shadow of the true mater's
Peaks is certainly an attractive goal
but like the challenging terrain Lara
needs to traverse the path there is
getting rougher and more unpredictable
[Music]
what if I don't
[ __ ] Jonah get to higher ground